Les gens racontent qu'il est nul à chier sur les jeux vidéos... !
Jeux de stratégies, jeux de combats, FPS, TPS
Il est nul à chier partout
Mais aujourd'hui il décide...
de vous jouer du Maître Gims au ukulélé
*Squeezie chante* Elle répondait au nom de Bella
FAUX
de vous prouver qu'il n'est pas si nul à chier
Il va le faire sur "PLAYERUNKNOWN'S BATTLEGROUNDS"
Vous vous souvenez la vidéo qu'on avait faire sur H1Z1
Avec Mika , Laink et terracid , Gota
L'escouade de luxe
Et bien le but c'était d’être le dernier en vie
Dans ce jeux c'est pareil le but c'est d’être le dernier en vie
On va être 100 à être projetés sur une map
Il faut s'armer , s'équipper à base de gilet-par-balle , de casque , de weapons,
et être le dernier en vie !
C'EST PARTI !
* Allez allez mes amis, allons faire ça ! *
On peut atterrir dans plusieurs villes, comme c'est noté ici,
et là on va atterrir à Yasnaya Polyana,
qui est une petite ville suisse très mignonne !
C'est entièrement faux, mais je vous aime quand même, amis suisses !
Ok ! Vous êtes prêts ? On la voit !
C'EST PARTI !
Direction "Vasliana Polyana"
Vous en faites pas, vous êtes avec le guide, je suis votre guide dans cette putain de vidéo !
Vous allez voir, on va CASSER DES CULS
Le but, ça va être de trouver une arme le plus vite possible,
et de regarder combien il y a de gens autour de nous.
Attends, il y en a un qui est là,
ok, je le repère comme ça je pourrai le défoncer.
On aterrit on atterit, c'est bon, c'est parti !
Let's go ! Clac, qu'est-ce qu'on a ici ?
OH PUTAIN ! OH PUTAIN c'est la folie !
AKM, hop, hop, hop !
Là, le but c'est de mettre son casque à fond,
pour entendre les ennemis arriver !
Un casque level 2. Mec, on se met bien !
Je vous jure qu'on se met bien, je me suis rarement mis aussi bien
Et regarde, on a un gilet de police avec !
Mais que demande le peuple ?
Oh oui, un fusil à pompe !
Les amis, je suis fier de vous annoncer qu'on se met méga bien,
et qu'on va tout de suite chercher la baston sur le mec qu'on a vu atterrir plus tôt !
Il va être en état de choc !
Ah putain, j'ai trouvé un adversaire plus fort que lui, c'est ce muret.
Je sais qu'il y a un mec pas loin, je peux sentir son odeur de fauve...
* renifle l'odeur de fauve *
Chuuuut ! Ils sont partout, dans les villes, dans les campagnes !
Mais nous on voit personne ! Les amis...
On se fait boycott quoi, on a zéro potes
Ok, plan B !
*Crie très fort*
Oh j'ai eu peur !
Faut boire de la boisson énergisante pour se soigner,
c'est vraiment bien fait !
Putain, j'ai pas vu d'où il m'a tiré dessus !
J'suis con putain !
Suivez le guide, ne paniquez pas !
La panique est un sentiment nul, alors débarrassez vous-en.
* Renifle *
Je suis terrifié là...
Alors, le blem' je vous explique, c'est qu'il y a un champ de force qui va se ramener dans pas longtemps,
et il faudra fuir ce champ de force, généralement, faudra aller dans le milieu du cercle ici.
* Coups de feu *
Chuuut !
Derrière nous, pas de panique, pas de panique, je gère !
Ok, vous l'avez vu ? On le prend en chasse, tel un cyborg,
et je parle pas de Nekfeu, ok ?
Alors on va le tuer, sur du Nekfeu car nous sommes insolents !
* Nekfeu en fond *
Ne paniquez pas !
Il est là, vous l'avez vu ? Il est juste là !
* Nekfeu en fond *
[ Incompréhensible ]
Fils de pute !
C'est bon, ça c'est fait !
Il y en a un autre
C'est mes bruits de pas à moi ou c'est...
*coups de feu*
TIENS !
Personne n'entrave une visite entre son guide et ses abonnés. Vous avez compris ?
Je le dis haut et fort !
Oh j'en tremble.
Maintenant que cette mise au point est fait regardons la map,
Donc comme on peut le voir je suis dans le cercle bleu et non dans le cercle blanc
Ce qui veut dire que QUAND, le champ de force va se rapprocher je serai dans la merde !
Faut qu'on s'barre...
Faut y aller c'est par là; droite messieurs dames !
On longe la route principale...
*souffle*
Alors ne jamais marcher sur les grandes routes comme-ça bien sûr non pas que vous allez vous faire écraser,
Mais vous allez vous faire chasser comme le mec là-bas vous voyez...
*coups de feu*
On l'a vu, on va...le...traquer !
Ah, ça ces les touristes qui ont plus...de thunes...que vous !
*voix robotique* À votre droite, vous-pouvez apercevoir des pauvres.
*voix en choeur* Ohhhhhh......
Et qui ont un guide, euh...carrément qui pilote un avion
Moi non, moi ça y a pas
Il est quelque part, je n'le vois pas, ça c'est très dangeureux...
Ok la prochaine zone a été indiquée, elle est a quelques mètres seulement on va traverser Rozhok.
*coup de feu*
Oh ! Hopopopo !
Alors soit un mec a tiré pas loin soit il joue avec du bison 4
En plus dans ce jeu, j'vais pas vous mentir les gens ADORENT camper à une put*in d'fenêtre,
Chut !
Est-ce que quelqu'un est en train de se raser les boules dans la maison ?
Ou c'est le bruit d'un véhicule ?
*tir*
Ohhhhhh !
Damn it !
Qui est le bâtard qui a voulu m'tirer dessus là ?!
Et mais y a un mec dans la maison...
Je vous JURE y a un mec dans cette maison j'ai entendu...
Vous l'entendez ?
*tir*
Vous entendez le vent ?
Pffffffff !
Oh la pute avec son gros Kar98 de bâtard !, c'est un sniper, il m'a one-shot...
C'est la fin du guide, bah voilà...
Le mec il devait être à une fenêtre comme ça,
Il attendait qu'un con s'arrête pour parler à sa communauté parce qu'il aime sa communauté, vous voyez ?
Et lui il l'aime pas, du coup il a fait quoi, pourquoi je fais l'geste Italien on sait pas non plus.
Hop là, dans ma tête !
Voilà donc tous ce qui le follow sur twitch
le mec et bah go l'unfollow
BON
Les amis on va atterrir ici a Pochinki bien sûr petite ville de la Lorraine
On apprécie la Lorraine, dédicace aux Lorrainiens (lorrains en fait)
Ok c'est parti
Et là faut juste prier pour que dans notre maison y'ait mon gars de quoi s'armer
Ok un casque
On est bien, on est bien, on est bien.
Eh c'est pas loin ça.
Ok y'a un mec qui est dans la maison les amis
Y'a un mec qui est dans la maison, paniquez pas paniquez pas. *Ré-armement d'une arme* Il arrive.
*Explosion*
Ok, y'a bel et bien un mec, il a envoyé une greu, il a tenté.
Beh viens, de quoi t'as peur gamin ? VIIIIENS
Tu peux prendre part à la visite sans problème,
Il suffit de payer ton ticket, comme tout ces gens.
ALLEZ, TU PAYES !
Regarde, il est là, il est là.
ET VOILA ! On en parle plus !
Fallait payer, fallait payer
Tarif réduit de quoi mec ? T'as 40 ans
Bon ça c'est fait.
Ok, on a un pompe maintenant